that welcome back to Hannity we continue
with Adam laxalt and Senator Tim Scott
the moment will be joined by Utah
Senator Mike Lee will join us all right
let's go over these issues when you talk
about the high crime I think Senator
Scott nailed we refund the police right
when we talk about high Gas and energy
prices we go back to energy Independence
not hard not that hard right it when we
talk about open borders we go back to
the Trump policies On the Border yes
Mexico finished the wall finish the wall
okay when we talk about Law and Order
and and when we talk about our school
system I don't think it's that
complicated why why did Democrats why
are they so against allowing parents to
choose where to send their kids to
school
it's part of this whole Elite mentality
they think they know better than we do
and so they think they have a world view
that they're supposed to impose on our
children and it's up to all of us to
fight back against that tooth and nail
what gives why do why do people on the
left think they can they have a specific
role to circumvent values that parents
want to instill in their kids and teach
them a I would argue in many cases age
inappropriate material and that's gender
identity that's you know sex whatever
drag queen yeah yeah I was going to
bring that up we are in Vegas you know
the the bottom line is that it is pure
radical indoctrination and they know
exactly what they're doing they have a
world view they want to impose it on our
kids and they know that parents don't
support this and they're going that next
step they're trying to criminalize
parents for trying to protect their kids
for a set of values that we all believe
in it's it's really getting out of
control is there anybody you speak to
that's against America being energy
independent because I don't meet a
single person
if they had to run on the green New Deal
and the ramifications they'd get no
votes we all know they just shove it
through the back end and the very first
election in modern time where people
actually get to vote on this with the
gas prices they're going to lose on this
issue dramatically this is my problem
with the Democrats that left go sell it
go tell America that the green New Deal
will equal it's going to be much higher
than six dollars a gallon we all know
that if he wasn't tapping the Strategic
Reserve it'd be higher than six bucks in
this state right now California now is
well over 650 a gallon you know by the
way you're getting a lot of people
moving from California here
we are I have an I have a message to
them if they're going to move here leave
their politics behind okay
don't need it here
[Applause]
stickers don't California or Nevada no
California
paternalism the Democrats are
paternalistic they think that they that
we all need parents think about that in
education 70 of African-Americans 74 of
Hispanics eighty percent of dual
households income households all agree
with school choice school choice is
common sense every single zip code in
America deserves quality education
they have sold been bought and sold by
Big labor unions in education it's not
the parents
it's Big labor that controls the
Democrats but they control them so
there's this Unholy Alliance right
between teachers unions and the
Democratic party yes and the teachers
unions take money from Rank and file
teachers they funnel it into Political
campaigns they help Democrats get
elected and then they get to write covet
policy uh that is not beneficial for
kids they're not putting kids at the top
of the list absolutely when I when I had
a piece of legislation to put kids back
into school
his opponent voted it down
the Biden Administration is responsible
for the largest drop in math scores in
the history of this country
I'm not saying a lot terrible
our kids deserve better
yeah they deserve better their parents
are standing up
and when the parents stand up
if the abiding administration's doj that
say that they're domestic terrorists
this is an alternate universe so we're
about to I can't believe it they're all
according to Chuck Grassley Ron Johnson
Jim Jordan there are 20 to 30 maybe more
FBI whistleblowers doj whistleblowers
that are telling the story that the FBI
has been politicized the doj has been
weaponized uh did we see that for
example contempt to Congress Jan arena
was held in contempt to Congress she
never got arrested she never she never
got charged uh you can go to Eric Holder
same thing with him a lowest learner
same thing with her Steve Bannon not
only arrested charged four months in
jail whether this shouldn't be political
is that equal application and is that
equal justice Lady Justice is not blind
yeah that's what we're seeing under this
Administration but we see it a lot and I
would just say is that the former Top
Cop of this state we work with line FBI
there's plenty of great FBI agents the
media tries to do this big gotcha when I
say that the top of the app FBI the
politicals have politicized this agency
and it's dangerous they have so much
power and if we're going to give them
this much power we darn well better
expect them to use it properly and the
fact of the matter is it's become hyper
politicized everybody knows it except
the media the mainstream media they're
completely ignoring it people are very
nervous about this out here in Nevada I
can tell you that how do you feel about
voter Integrity issues in Nevada and I
ask you that question through this prism
you might remember Harry Reid pretty
famous interview said we we won didn't
we when asked whether or not it was an
honest election I think you know the
quote I'm talking about my question is
do you worry about it do you feel that
that what they did in 2020 90 days
before the election the Democrats went
in with no Republican votes and they
gave us the first ever Universal
mail-out balloting election ballot
harvesting was a felony day 91 became
the legal method of voting day 90. and
so it's a system that we thought on our
side we were not ready for and you know
we can't relitigate 2020. uh it is
better now we have more poll workers we
have more poll Watchers but in the end
of the day nevadans have to turn out we
need a new governor we need to get rid
of ballot harvesting Dropbox and
Universal man
maybe I'm old-fashioned what if we made
voting a national holiday now for the
sick the infirmed the elderly we can
have they can have mail-in ballots that
they request or if you're going to be
out of the country or out of the state
you still would like to vote and
participate but why not paper ballots in
every state have partisan observers all
sides watch the vote count start to
finish you fill out your paper ballot
you put it in the box at the end of the
night they dump them out they start
counting everybody watches it up close
and and in person and we get the result
at the end of the night
is that hard
just
every single thing we do to make sure
that every single American has
confidence in voting is very important
the laws that we've seen change on the
state level like in Georgia has actually
produced stronger voters Jim Crow 2.0
that's why I went to the floor of the
Senate and said those people must be
smoking crack because they've lost their
minds literally I shouldn't say that on
TV
it's too late now think about it this
way think about trying to think about
this thing in Georgia they said asking
for water from a nonpartisan
was Jim Crow 2.0 I'm a man from the
south a black man from the south that is
offensive I remember Jim Crow I remember
the stories my grandfather told me when
I look at the laws in Georgia they are
so far away from Jim Crow and as a
matter of fact the proof is in the
pudding this cycle
this cycle the largest African-American
turnout in the history of Georgia
Republicans care about voting and we
want fairness in voting hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else